no ok non funziona perché sono riusciti
infatti a bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono fa vj oggi
siamo su è una casa è una casa a
grossissima allora e sono con marci e
marco volevo capire una roba allora
l'infermiere ragazzi ve lo spiego
l'infermiera cambia ogni volta che
facciamo quindi oggi è così l'infermiera
oggi oggi ha il corpo da sirena le
antenne insomma lei infermiera cambia
aspetto ma non cambia una cosa l'amore
che ha nei miei confronti
vabbè vabbè allora siamo davanti a
questa casa gigante ci spiega lei che
cosa dobbiamo fare allora
ben ritrovati ragazzi fin qua sta deve
provare cosa significa essere
all'inferno bene questa cosa non mi
piace questa villa abbandonata e la
dimora degli assi cp più mostruosi
l'unico modo che avete per uscire dalla
porta principale ma quest'ultima si
aprirà soltanto tra 24 ore quindi 24 ore
sono venti minuti minecraft rifiuti su
mike rann non potete fare altro che
resistere cercate di non morire
soprattutto tuffa vige tesoro voi potete
morire c'è scritto quello io armiamoci
perché sentito che questa è una è una
maggiore di minecraft di manninger certo
si è bianca però però dentro vedo non
vedo niente mi sono cagato addosso
quindi ragazzi direi che a questo punto
con un cuore in meno e anche la dignità
in meno io entra
non vi sia piaciuto oggi finisce così è
finito a pieno le armi spesa spetta a me
andiamo a salvarli il deretano apre la
porta ai varco aprì la porta da solo non
c'è da lui è morto è morto e finisce
aprite non c'e la chiave io ok grazie
così è successo qua spiega mi ha cercato
per te razionale chi è che mi sta
sparando ragazzi possiamo stare un
attimo care è difficile la situazione
gestirlo però che chi era queste cifre
da quello io non ti consiglio allora
aspetto ogni o spiego no c'è uno che
compartecipi e 172 e giusto
163 manuale che spiega di un nulla sa
che col piccoli disegni non si può
colpire macino trovare quello di
diamante probabilmente sì va bene se ne
frega ormai il timer scorre occhio fissa
lo è ma si torna chester lui c'è un
accesso aspetto c'è un pdv colpi tv il
primato negativo fisso lui capisce
perché tieni ritieni fabi ciampi tv
grazie è bello fino alla serie
attenzioni che casini a fare parkour
quando abbiamo mai per cui facciamo
perché ormai non come dietro ragazzi non
come pietro tra vinto come io tu spinto
canestro
ma sta saltando ma guarda che lesse cp
173 è morto marco da sole ma le sei
morto da solo ma non ho fatto niente e
fa vinci girati girati lori lo riguarda
la croce la luce dietro il mio dio anche
a posto ma le 16 è di 173 cade nella
lava dio vi aspetto non è lava sensibile
aiuto che male che male non si fa
ripetuto
ecco marcello risi sento bene quasi però
rileva ragazzino resisteremo mai tutta
la notte sono vivo per miracolo
la regalo non mi toccare tipo che voglio
anche grazie ai ho veramente pochi i
cuori ok
qual è la casa si è dotato rigirate lo
fisso io l'ho messo io ok ragazzi allora
lo rimini con me chi è quello vedi
quella sì quella è la donna palude ce ne
sono tre altro ha lanciato a destra se
ti colpisce lei 6 fitto perché ti fa un
sacco di danno allora perfetto
buongiorno non guardarlo non guardarlo
nori ok bravissimi e fortissima c'è solo
freddo almeni poi ma ci rincontriamo
schifoso maledetto per un attimo mi
dicono se nino segreta mi sarà perfetto
ma almeno quello che siamo
passano i nostri cibi voi le scuole
sgonico non c'è niente se mi ha superato
ascoltiamo fatto lungo su cuocere cesko
c'è sempre di più piccole i diamanti
alla gamma siamo fare fuori scp 0 173
missy ridotte con la gioco
e morto oggi ho tirato da capo una
picconata in bocca ok grazie che avevo
solo un cuore di vita
prego prego usciamo con ricordi però
abbiamo già oliva veloci vieni quaratino
aia che vale ma basta di consiglio tocca
col tasto destro il vaso the ok prova ci
sto facendo come succederà una cosa non
farina no ok non funziona perché sono
già usciti in pratica ma siete scemi
voi siete share ma cos'è successo lì ma
ragazzi ma imparano meglio occhio c'è la
mano destra come l'ansia madonna quasi
cp è quello da palo del numero e 813
dovrebbe essere gli dici questo wanna cc
non mi ricordo la mia ragazza di luca
torino c'era stata la mia vita
basta basta basta quasi quanti passi
esistono no no no no no astana ma il
quadro quello che fa danno come c'è
quadro che fa danno la destra là in
fondo
sc piquadro vai vai con il quadro allora
in pratica cos'è questo qui scp 151 ma
sono vuote
è come se dovesse replicare replicare
l'oceano quando ti soffoca dove dichiarò
ma mi sa che è previsto però toglierlo
grazie della spiegazione non voglio
morire no a ragazzotto ho fatto un danno
che si è fatto un daniel ha sbottato
lantern favore dell'aiuto di scrivente
troppa la aspetta un attimo non
guardatelo el avete guardato e non ne
sto fissando el'ass
se non lo spacchiamo prima che uccide
etici di mori e spacchiamo il pezzo
sotto non è primo in febbraio
ok che nascessimo sto seguendo la fiera
dove si ho trovato anti hazard suite
mettila e potentissimo via ebrei lo sono
entrato tipo 1 di power ranger
poi c'è una sala lan oddio che è
successo mi sono le pistole atomizzati
casinò sono tre per i leoni ma possibile
fare pistola aiutatemi aiutatemi uniti
ma che bella essa pistola prossimi senza
chi sta roba qua per forza esce gente no
lory non farlo maria vianney perché
avete pensava non ci sono più simili
usciti male scappava berrù che l'opera
di sopra e notte non so dove ti faccio
cambiare io mi ha toccato a miane
avvelenato tizio no no no no glory
non ho poi guardarla un momento no ma
indietro basta che male c'è elevando a
tokyo dietro vengo anche io non posso
parlare perché mi attaccano da dietro
guarda se io colpisco lei
a noi o no march non è stata da lei non
sono stato io no guarda quindi danno
tutto ma non puoi nemmeno pare un po
lasciato lì non lo stesso danno che ti
per essere hai capito
ma davvero è sì in varie luco la pistola
faglielo con la pistola guarda quando si
toglie quindi praticamente è il portale
e può morire solo con la tnt lei ha
questo potere o di oggi deve star ma mi
fa cagare ragazzi io posso dire non
funziona questo qua e là detto miser non
hanno un dato mi dà niente neanche le
fatine è la stanza della ragazzina nella
stanza sua mamma alma fa streaming è un
casino qua al pc basterà la fibra
ragazzi oggi csc pizza 99 ritrovata
seguire questo da 99 è un women i voice
1939 mi sembra che male ragazzi
i vigili troviamo se di qua c'è qualcosa
nel male mi ha fatto c'è nel vino questa
è la mia non potente di sempre me la
presi un secondo per cortesia che voglio
vedere tempo lavora contro un scp prova
quella di prima dovete le ha ucciso l'ex
integrato marzo scusami ho sbagliato ma
doveva aveva che casino fa quest'arma
crea i buchi cosa però c'è qualcosa o ti
trovi gli outlet con bud leggins sono i
lakers più potenti della moda guarda
davvero sono alla moda per un in cima
c'è scp bancomat
c'è anche se cps lunga poiché sappiamo
avere catene
no no no no no no no no no no e farcela
fare la verità devi dietro di te e alla
tua sinistra è uscito ma se io non posso
distogliere lo sguardo in questo momento
che male non si fa niente male
ha fatti cadere di sotto fortino non
credo
ottima didietro marcia indietro ok il
libro di è pieno ma vacci tu sei messo
davanti io poi ho sempre col spazi si è
messo davanti un no per niente non è
stata di fuori quelli a presidi sotto
c'è il muro capito sparo vincolo solo
col piccone muoiono è vero che pirla e
ragazzi non il piccone io come fa sì
come no cioè i piccoli di legno e quelli
diamante non lo so la pro trovato per
sbaglio sono fregati a livelli estremi
come un piccone con sciarpe cinque
minuti lo so era era utilissimo l'ho
perso aperta potrebbe ma non lo so
ragazzi possibile ragazzi anche a voi
cosa a me è sposata una carta di livello
5 nel nell'inventario separata da casa
ieri 5 via via che siamo uscire quindi
quindi possiamo uscire ha via via via
via scendiamo vabbè buttiamo ecco i
fatti
volevo fare questa fine non volevo fare
questa fine velino mi sono buttato va bè
ragazzi a sfondo all'inizio dell'avere
vai vai veloce ma che guardate me ma non
è l'alba o che non sia in realtà c'è
l'alba che figata arrivo corro io e
laporta
ma non va riuscì ad arte avete tutto la
finestra che fate ok è vero e l'alba
ragazzi ce l'abbiamo
oggi l'abbiamo fatta è un parolone dai
ragazzi questo è di quanto è stato molto
molto molto di feedback che sta qua
penso sia stata la mappa di scpp il
difficile per adesso per me è un esempio
mamma mi ha veramente un casino
ringrazio i ragazzi per per essere morti
sotto il fuoco amico
grazie dispiace march veramente non
voleva uccidere te il mio obiettivo ma
per la scuol questo e altro non sa bene
a tutti con me c'erano capitolo
ma lui e va bene spero che vi sia
piaciuto
vi ringrazio per la visto video
iscrivetevi al canale come in ogni video
totti descrizione del tasso iscriviti
vicina con la bellissima campanella che
volete schiacciare perché vi arrivano le
notifiche dei video e lascio anche
canale i ragazzi in descrizione noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
quindi bella ragazza
[Musica]